tout d'abord je vais très bien je ne
sais pas pour vous comment vous allez
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
un retour au premier plan fracassant
plus d'une semaine après avoir été testé
positif aux copies de 19
donald trump s'est offert une sortie
publique ce samedi soir surplombant une
foule amassée devant la maison blanche
le président américain relance sa
campagne et veut d'abord rassurer grâce
à la puissance de l'esprit américain
plus que toute autre chose
la science et la médecine devons
éradiquer le virus chinois une fois pour
toutes
nous allons nous en débarrasser dans le
monde entier vous voyez de grandes
flambées en europe de grandes flambées
au canada comme vous avez vu aujourd'hui
beaucoup de flamber mais le virus va
disparaître il est en train de
disparaître les vaccins vont aider et
les thérapies vont beaucoup aidé une
sortie étonnante est critiqué quatre
jours seulement après être sorti de
l'hôpital même si le médecin du
président américain a précisé qu'il
n'était plus contagieux
la maison blanche n'a pas divulgué le
résultat du dernier test de donald trump
impossible donc de savoir si ce dernier
est désormais négatif ou non ce soir je
suis heureux d'annoncer qu'en plus du
fait que le président remplit tous les
critères des cdc pour une cessation en
sécurité d'isolement au regard des
standards actuellement reconnue il n'est
plus considéré comme risquant de
transmettre le virus à d'autres
personnes
cette sortie publique de donald trump
aux allures de meeting électoral était
la première d'une longue série
au plus bas dans les sondages le
milliardaire se rendra lundi en floride
mardi en pennsylvanie et mercredi dans
l'iowa des déplacements alors que le
président américain est au plus bas dans
les sondages avec seulement 42 %
d'intentions de vote pour s'en prendre à
son rival joe biden le président
américain a tenu à se défendre sur les
récents événements liés au mouvement
black light matters et je le dis j'ai
fait plus pour la communauté noire que
tout autre président depuis abraham
lincoln jeu
dix personnes ne peut être en désaccord
et que cela personne ne peut être en
désaccord et c'est vrai en marge de ce
discours un rassemblement pro trump
avait lieu devant la maison blanche
un cortège organisé par un mouvement
conservateur qui encourage les électeurs
afro américain a quitté le parti
démocrate
une dernière ligne droite crucial attend
donald trump
avec près de 10 points de retard dans
les sondages le président américain a
fait part de son envie d'aller sur le
terrain
à trois semaines de l'élection
présidentielle